is Loki due for another And Timely death
could Spider-Man be swinging into
another Cinematic Universe Phase 5 of
the MCU is upon us but Heroes beware not
everyone is going to make it out alive
Hulk and by extension Bruce Banner is
one of the mcu's oldest characters he
first made his debut in the 2008 film
The Incredible Hulk a month after Iron
Man and had a starring role in 2012's
The Avengers outside of a select few
superheroes such as Thor and Hawkeye and
also makes him one of the only
characters who has survived up until
this point with most of his fellow
heroes from phase one of the MCU gone it
could be the Hulk's story is near an end
of course the timing would make sense as
Bruce has essentially reached a balance
in his life both his personalities have
effectively merged into one individual
giving birth to the smart Hulk figure we
see in Avengers end game this character
combines the strength of the Hulk or the
intelligence of banner and season end to
the internal struggle the hero has been
enduring for several years now that his
story has come full circle it could be a
good time for him to leave the MCU
especially since he has helped train
She-Hulk as a potential replacement
there's also a rights issue that looms
over the whole dog stopping Disney and
Marvel Studios from being able to create
a standalone movie actor Mark Ruffalo
explained that Universal owns the rights
to any film focusing entirely on the
Hulk meaning Disney is limited in what
it can do with him Vision has had a
rough ride in the MCU created by Ultron
Tony Stark Thor and Bruce Banner the
synthesis was brought to life with the
help of the Mind Stone after battling
alongside the Avengers against Ultron
and sokovia he and his fellow Heroes
decided to destroy the Mind Stone in an
attempt to sub Thanos from capturing it
a process that led to Visions death at
the hands of his lover Wanda maximoff
unfortunately Thanos reverse time and
brought Vision back to life only to kill
him a second time by forcibly removing
the Mind Stone from his head a
recreation of the character was brought
into existence by Wonder using chaos
magic in one division while sword
develops their own version known as
white Vision by reassembling his Parts
following the basil of wakanda
considering how the character has been
killed multiple times already a more
final death sooner rather than later
seems in the cards
at the moment it still isn't clear what
the future holds for vision white Vision
now believes himself to be the true
version of the hero as the only
remaining vision and is whereabouts are
known following the events of One
Division Paul Bettany also confirmed in
2022 that he doesn't have a contract of
Marvel Studios so his character's days
appear numbered although a show
featuring white Vision may be in the
works
although he hasn't been as important to
the wider MCU as some of his
counterparts Hank Pym is a significant
player in the Ant-Man films yes I'm
still alive he is said to appear in the
third entry in the series Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania in early 2023 in
which you'll explore the quantum realm
with Scott Lang hope Van Dyne and Janet
Van Dyne trailers have revealed that the
group will encounter Kang the Conqueror
in the quantum realm which might not be
good news for Pym after all akan was
first introduced in Loki in 2021 as the
next big villain in the form of he who
remains a variant who dedicated his life
to stopping more evil variants of
himself from being able to take over all
of existence Marvel Studios revealed
phase six will conclude with two
Avengers movies with the first being
Avengers the Kang Dynasty this suggests
that kangna conqueror will be similar to
Thanos and proved to be a major villain
going forward if that's the case there
would be no better way to introduce him
to movie-going audiences as a huge
threat than if he killed a major to
character Pym would fit the bill in that
sense he is already an older figure and
has passed on most of his knowledge to
Scots hope and Janet his death can
provide the heroes of the MCU with
plenty of motivation to take on the time
traveling super villain Kang the
Conqueror
James Rhodes also known as war machine
is one of the most senior members of The
Avengers he made his debut in Iron Man
where he was portrayed by Terence Howard
before being replaced by Don Cheadle in
Iron Man 2. while he's played a somewhat
significant role in the franchise he has
never had a standalone film or been the
main focus of a movie or television show
in fact Rose has been largely absent
since Avengers end game except for a
small role in the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier a close associate of Tony Stark
war machine will take on an important
role in Phase 5. Samuel Jackson
confirmed that Cheeto would appear in
the upcoming Disney plus series secret
Invasion meanwhile the character has
been confirmed to Star on the television
series turned movie armor Wars so James
Rhodes certainly has a future in the MCU
it's just unclear for how much longer
the ACT has confirmed he is no longer
under contract with Marvel which might
well be a hint that his future in the
MCU franchise is in doubt war machine
has faced death before most notably
during the airport battle scene in
Captain America America Civil War and he
may not have that many lucky escapes
left in him his death would certainly be
a major event especially following the
passing of his close friend Iron Man
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 has
something of a finale feel to it and
fans have been speculating for some time
that it could see the deaths of several
key characters Chief among them is
Rocket Raccoon the cynical sentient
animal that has been at the center of
the ragtag team of mercenaries
throughout all of their appearances in
the MCU director James Gunn spoke about
the new film acting as a way of wrapping
up rocket story and exploring his
Origins a trailer for the film appears
to show a young rockets and features the
heroes saying that he has done running
combine that with the fact that gun has
previously said that he would explore
Rocket's gruesome origin story which he
described in MCU exchange as a little
bit more horrible than what it is in the
comics when you come down to it
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 will begin's
last MCU project for the foreseeable
future as he's now in charge of the DC
film Universal Warner Brothers all this
plus the fact that Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 appears of a more somber
tone my Mina fans should get the tissues
ready at the very least seeing Rockets
full story unfold won't be easy viewing
nebula is another member of the
Guardians of the Galaxy who could see
her time in the MCU come to an end
during phase five You could argue that
the adoptive daughter of Thanos has had
one of the most Redemptive story arcs of
any character in the series having gone
from a single-minded antagonist who
wanted nothing more than revenge on her
stepsister Gamora to reconciling with
Gamora and joining the heroes in the
fight against a mad Titan exactly what
Karen gillen's situation is in terms of
her contract with Disney for the MCU
hasn't been made public however she has
spoken about how much she enjoys playing
the character in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter saying I really like
playing her so I'm not eager to finish
however that doesn't mean she will get
to continue portraying nebula in the
future and Gillen has even suggested in
an Instagram post that Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 could be the final outing
for nebula considering everything that
has gone on between Gamora and nebula it
might be fitting to have one of them
sacrifice themselves for the other if
that were the case a sensible bet would
be for nebula to take the fall as it was
best suit our overall narrative as
someone who has changed so much over the
last decade Drax is another long time
member of the Guardians of the Galaxy
and a familiar face in the MCU he also
has one of the more tragic backstories
of any hero in the franchise that's
primarily because his beef with Thanos
was far more personal than many others
as Ronan the Accuser killed his wife and
daughter as part of his alliance with
the Mad Titan that means that his entire
motivation and everything he has done in
the Guardians of the Galaxy films has
been tinged with sorrow despite finding
a new family in the Guardians of the
Galaxy draxa Destroyer clearly still
Mourns the loss of his family and it
seems almost certain that he will
reunite with them at some point having
that happen at the conclusion of
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 would be a
fitting end for a warrior who has stood
against some of the biggest threats the
universe has seen it would also give him
the chance to perhaps save his new
family in some sort of heroic act before
going to his final reward and in the end
see my wife and daughter again throw in
the fact that actor Dave Batista has
been very clear about the next film
being his last in the MCU and it seems
almost certain that Drexel meet his end
as a character's story comes to a
natural conclusion Thor is somewhat
unique in the MCU not only is he one of
the few characters who has been around
since the Avengers in 2012 but he has
also had four solo movies with the most
recent being Thor love and thunder yet
he still hasn't had a defining moment to
say goodbye like Captain America or Iron
Man that could well change in the future
with Chris Hemsworth telling Vanity Fair
that any future appearances in the MCU
would probably be the finale for the
Norse god the ending of Thor love and
thunder provided some closure to a
character who has been on a constant
search for meaning since his first
appearance now a father to his adoptive
daughter love he may have found his true
place in the universe and be able to
settle down of course having his art
come to an end might also mean he could
die causing his legacy to live on in
those he considers part of his family
including Korg and love its story will
have to come to an end at some point and
having him involved in a battle with
Kung the Conqueror would be a perfect
way to do it the actor has also
announced that he is taking a step back
from acting following his recent
discovery that he carries an increased
risk of developing Alzheimer's disease
later in life
at the beginning of the MCU Nick Fury
was a staple that helped hold all of the
various films and television series
together he has been involved in 11 MCU
movies and was responsible for creating
the Avengers Initiative yet Fury has
largely been absent from the franchise
in recent years outside of brief
appearances or cameos all that is about
to change with the release of the
television series secret Invasion and
the movie the Marvels which will seize
Samuel Jackson reprise a character in
starring roles still while Fury will no
doubt have an important part to play in
those two projects his influence over
events in Phase 5 still isn't clear and
with his significance seemingly waning
it may be time for the former director
of Shield to meet his maker after all
Fury has already come close to death on
several occasions and could provide a
lot of inspiration to the heroes Left
Behind many of whom he has a close
relationship with if he was killed it
would be appropriate to have Fury full
now that he has such a legacy built up
that will last long after his demise
few people would have thought that Loki
would become the Beloved character he
has since his introduction yet his story
in the MCU is a bit hard to follow
mainly due to his complicated timeline
within the franchise the character has
gotten from villain to anti-hero to a
devoted Ally of Thor in his fight
against Thanos yet he has also been
killed by The Mad Titan and lives on in
the form of a variant who starred in the
Disney plus series Loki the god of
mischief's story is set to continue in
Loki season 2. although it's unclear how
much of a role will play in the rest of
phase 5. Marvel Studios still hasn't
confirmed that the character will appear
in any other projects thus despite the
fact that Tom Hiddleston has confirmed
he would like to keep playing Loki for
as long as possible taking into account
that Loki has already been killed and
will no doubts have to confront Kang the
Conqueror after he and his female
variant Sylvie and Lisa villain upon the
Multiverse then it seems likely he could
die of course there wouldn't be anything
stopping other potential variants from
continuing
Spider-Man is one of the mcu's biggest
and most successful Heroes he's become a
significant figure in the franchise
working alongside Iron Man doctor
strange and the rest of the Avengers but
the ending of Spider-Man no way home
effectively made everyone forget that
Peter Parker exists this not only gave
the hero the anonymity to operate as an
independent figure outside of the
Avengers but also allows Sony to remove
him from the MCU altogether Sony and
Disney have had difficulty working
together and only shook a last minute
deal to keep Holland in the MCU back in
2019.
it's possible that Peter Spider-Man
could depart the MCU at some point but
others could follow in his web steps
apart from a brief Easter egg reference
in Spider-Man homecoming Miles Morales
has been entirely absent from the MCU
but the latest movie did introduce the
idea of different versions of the web
slinging hero so it's possible miles
could show up he could even be a
potential replacement for the mcu's
Peter Parker and the events that are and
Spidey dies the Winter Soldier otherwise
known as Bucky Barnes has gone through
one of the biggest transformations of
any character within the MCU once a
friend and Ally of Steve Rogers Barnes
was transformed into a super soldier
Assassin by Hydra however he was
eventually able to overcome its
programming with the help of Captain
America and king t'challa of wakanda now
a hero in his own right he has most
recently fought against the flag
Smashers alongside Sam Wilson in the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier in an
interview with uprox Sebastian Stan
revealed that he feels Bucky has earned
himself a comfortable death stating
hopefully at this point it would be in a
nice warm bed as a 200 year old man with
a family that's his way now I think he's
earned that of course that doesn't mean
that's how it will go down and with the
character confirmed to be part of the
Thunderbolts movie his team up with the
likes of Red Guardian Taskmaster and U.S
agent in 2024 may not be smooth sailing
exactly what is in store for Bucky
following as Redemption isn't obvious so
he may end up dying as a way of passing
the torch onto a new group of Heroes now
that his story has been told
[Music]